j'aimerais vous poser une question si la
réponse est oui vous levez la main si la
réponse est non le vais pas là-bas voilà
la question qui parmi vous êtes
intelligent lever la main c'est
intéressant d'abord j'en ai vu qui ont
levé la main spontanément d'autres qui
enlevait la main en hésitant et d'autres
qui ont mis leurs mains au fond de leur
poche peut-être en serrant le poing très
fortement cette question intéressante
qu'on la pose à des petits enfants tous
lèvent spontanément la main ils sont
tous intelligents quand la pause à des
enfants un peu plus grands ou bien
qu'ils sont adolescents
ça dépend des notes à l'école s'ils ont
des bonnes notes ils sont intelligents
ils lèvent la main si ils ont des
mauvaises notes ils sont bêtes stupide
creta imbéciles paresseux doit mieux
faire etc
ils sont pas intelligents bien entendu
et il ne lève pas la main curieusement
qu on pose la question aux enseignants
souvent les enseignants ne lève pas la
main c'est pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas
intelligent bien entendu c'est parce
qu'ils se disent où est le piège
cette question elle m'est tombé dessus
il ya près de 20 ans dans une vie
antérieure j'étais enseignant et je
revenais d'un voyage scolaire et pendant
le voyage scolaire j'avais découvert
bien entendu que certains de mes élèves
avait des talents tout à fait
insoupçonnées extraordinaire comme bien
tenir une caméra ou résoudre les
conflits entre les élèves de retour dans
le lycée de la banlieue parisienne jeudi
mais comment ça se fait certains de ces
élèves ont des talents tout à fait
étonnant et ils sont en échec scolaire
comment est ce possible d'avoir tant de
talent et être en échec et tout à coup
leur échec est devenu mon propre échec
alors j'ai creusé la question
ça m'a conduit plusieurs fois aux états
unis en australie et dans mes recherches
je suis tombé sur une vision de
l'intelligence très comment dire très
rafraîchissant et très faciles à
comprendre et très riche à la fois la
théorie des intelligences multiples
d'howard garner alors j'en parle depuis
assez longtemps et je me souviens d'une
conférence que j'ai fait une fois dans
un lycée technique dans une banlieue
difficile il y avait les élèves devant
moi les enseignants derrière à la fin de
ma conférence sur les intelligences
multiples il ya une jeune fille
une élève qui lève la main et qui peut
et qui dit monsieur si je vous ai bien
compris
moi aussi je suis intelligent oui vous
êtes bien entendu vous aussi vous êtes
intelligent comme nous tous l'étonnant
est venue après c'est lorsqu'un
enseignant m'a dit que cette jeune fille
était en profond échec scolaire et ce
jour là
ce jour-là à la compris que elle aussi
elle était intelligente est vraiment
intelligent et à partir de là on peut
commencer à construire ou à reconstruire
là ce que la personnalité a été abîmée
alors de quoi s'agit-il
d'après howard garner nous avons tous
potentiellement pourrait dire dans notre
adn
huit formes d'intelligence nous les
avons tout en abaissant ce
potentiellement et elles forment notre
bouquet d'intelligence vous voyez ce
beau jeune homme il à son bouquet
l'intelligence dans la main dans ce
bouquet ya hui fleurs mais vous remarqué
que certaines sont bien développées et
d'autres sont moins bien développé tout
ça pour dire que en général il ya des
intelligences que nous développons bien
et d'autres intelligences que nous
laissons plus ou moins en sommeil
quelles sont ces intelligences c'est
très simple un enfants de grande section
de maternelle peut comprendre ce que je
vais vous dire j'en ai été témoin
prenons des exemples vous êtes chez vous
avec votre conjoint votre conjointe et
vous adorez faire tourner les meubles
alors tient le canapé on va le mettre
ici le meuble de la grand-mère que
j'aime pas on va le mettre là ton
fauteuil préféré voilà vous vous créez
des images mentales
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
visuel spatiale ou bien vous adorez le
bruit le feulement d'un v8 à gros v8 le
bruit d'un moteur extraordinaire
ou bien vous trouvez que toute la beauté
du monde se trouve dans un opéra de
mozart
c'est une autre manière d'être
intelligent l'intelligence musicale
rythmique ou bien vous adorez les mots
tout ce qui concerne les mots les mots
qu'on dit qu'on écrit qu'on entend qu'on
parle c'est encore une forme
d'intelligence d'intelligence verbal
linguistique ou bien vous adorez aussi
tout ce qui est logique la cause des
conséquences tout ce qui est
mathématique scientifique intelligence
logique mathématique ou bien encore vous
êtes bien dans votre corps vous êtes à
l'aise à votre corps vous savez faire
des choses très précises
vous avez dansé vous aimez faire un
sport très précisément ou bien vous
aimez bricoler construire intelligence
corporelle ou encore vous adorez la
nature vous adorez l'observer vous
adorez classer les choses les arbres les
animaux les cailloux l'intelligence
naturalise et deux autres intelligence
encore une intelligence pour rentrer en
contact avec les autres l'intelligence
inter personnelles et l'intelligence
pour mieux se connaître l'intelligence
intra personnel connaît ses forces ses
faiblesses
voilà c'est tout un enfant qu'on peut
comprendre ça et quand on découvre cette
théorie on dit bon sang mais c'est bien
sûr pourquoi on m'avait dit ça avant
tout est clair alors il ya vingt ans
quand j'ai découvert ça ça n'intéressait
personne
maintenant on en parle plus d'une
manière parfois pas très maligne une
fois
un journaliste m'a contacté en dix ans
j'aimerais bien écrire un article sur
les intelligences multiples niveaux très
bien et l'ajustement 8 intelligence et
beaucoup est-ce qu'on pourrait pas en
prendre que trois ou quatre binômes dans
un an on prend toutes les intelligences
parce qu'on en a besoin de tout
on en a on a besoin de tout c'est
intelligent voilà mais il ya un endroit
où ça fait mal quand on appuie c'est
l'école il a souvent été remarqué que
notre système d'éducation de favoriser
et l'utiliser que deux formes
d'intelligence 2 sur 8
c'est à dire que l'école on n'utilise
jamais on ne développe jamais ou
quasiment jamais les trois quarts de nos
intelligences 6 sur 8 et même on les
pourchassent par exemple vous prenez un
enfant qui a une intelligence inter
personnelles très forte pour lui pour
lui pour apprendre pour réfléchir pour
mémoriser pour tous il faut qu'ils
parlent c'est nécessaire et ça va se
traduire par parle toujours à ses
camarades sera collé deux heures samedi
voilà du côté de dévaluation voilà un
dessin il ya un éléphant un singe un
poisson rouge
un phoque est un pingouin et le monsieur
à sa table dit afin d'assurer une
sélection juste et correct la consigne
sera la même pour tous grimpez sur la
route c'est ce que fait le système
scolaire souvent cette phrase vient
d'une phrase d'albert einstein dont il
était question tout à l'heure albert
einstein disait demandé un poisson de
grimper à un arbre et il se considèrera
comme un crétin toute sa vie eh oui
parce que un poisson lui il est bien
dans l'eau il est fort dans l'eau donc à
la fois cette manière d'évaluer cette
manière d'enseigner qu'on a dans notre
système ça qui est ça crée
essentiellement deux choses sacrées
d'abord beaucoup de souffrance ça crée
beaucoup de souffrances pour les élèves
qui réussissent pas à l'école parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les bonnes formes
d'intelligence et ça crée même des
souffrances chez les élèves qui sont
bons à l'école parce que d'une certaine
manière on les ampute de 6 intelligence
dont on pourrait se servir pour bien
réussir à l'école donc sacré beaucoup de
souffrance et curieusement c'est une
souffrance qui touche énormément
d'enfants d'adolescents et à une époque
où on s'apitoie beaucoup et ce qui est
normal sur la souffrance des enfants
c'est une souffrance qui laisse tout le
monde indifférent
c'est comme ça les enfants souffrent à
l'école qu'un important donc sacré
beaucoup de souffrance et ça crée aussi
beaucoup d'échecs
un chercheur américain bruce campbell
affirme et je serai prêt elles suivent
que 80% des échecs scolaires pourraient
être évités uniquement en introduisant
une pédagogie intelligences multiples
dans l'enseignement
c'est à dire en sollicitant
régulièrement toutes les huit formes
d'intelligence 80% des échecs scolaires
pourraient très vite et que fait le
gouvernement
citoyens de tous les pays exigeons des
gouvernements intelligences multiples
voilà un programme intéressant un
programme poliquin politique intéressant
nous exigeons les huit intelligence que
les huit intelligence prennent le
pouvoir
bon on peut rêver qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire de ça alors d'abord il faut le
reconnaître c'est intelligent là il ya
en gros une bonne manière et une
mauvaise manière de faire la mauvaise
manière de faire c'est de faire des
tests les tests sont totalement
contraires à l'esprit intelligences
multiples qui est une approche
respectueuse de l'intelligence et de la
personnalité humaine alors les tests in
à plat sur internet et sur internet
vous tomberez sur plein de tests évitez
les le meilleur moyen c'est
l'observation
observez vous vous même observer les
autres et petit à petit découvrez le
bouquet d'intelligence que chacun a et
que vous avez après on peut l'utiliser
en famille pour développer toutes les
intelligences de ses enfants ils
voulurent vous en seront reconnaissants
toute leur vie on peut l'utiliser avec
les devoirs à la maison
c'est à dire aider l'enfant à trouver
ces intelligences forte et lui permettre
de lutter de d'utiliser ces indigents
sorte le plus possible et même dans la
vie professionnelle
imaginez un projet d'avis un chef de
projet une équipe projet plutôt que de
prendre dans l'équipe projet des clones
du chef de projet prenez toutes les
intelligences fait en sorte que toutes
les intelligences sont représentés et
vous verrez que votre projet va
fonctionner beaucoup mieux ça marche
très bien aussi dans le monde du travail
une fois j'ai reçu un message d'un
monsieur qui m'a beaucoup touché j'y
vois là il m'a raconté
il m'a dit il avait 35 ans il m'a dit
mon parcours scolaire a été une
souffrance
il employait le mot souffrance mon
parcours scolaire a été une souffrance
de la maternelle jusqu'à l'université
sans arrêt pourquoi parce que il était
un élève médiocre et y sentez cette
médiocrité dans le comportement et dans
le langage des enseignants qui est là
la plupart des enseignants qu'il a eu et
il en a souffert toute sa scolarité et
enfin il sort du système scolaire et là
bas ils travaillent ils emploient on va
dire c'est intelligent ce comme il
l'entend et la russie réussit
brillamment alors il se dit je suis
schizophrène pas possible j'étais
médiocre maintenant je réussi
brillamment qu'est ce qui se passe avant
de consulter un psychiatre de bain mais
il va sur internet et il découvre les
intelligences multiples et il me dit mme
écrit j'ai cru que monsieur garner
parler de moi il avait deux
intelligences ultra forte jamais
sollicité à l'école donc médiocre à
l'école
brillant dans son travail et il termine
son message par une phrase très
importante
il disait comment je peux faire pour
éviter la souffrance que j'ai vécu à ma
petite fille de 4 ans et là on touche un
point très important parce que cette
souffrance
elle est vécue par d'innombrables
enfants par d'innombrables adolescents
et qui vont devenir des adultes souvent
qu'ils vont être soi est un soin et gris
et qui vont vouloir se venger de leur
mauvaise note et peut être que parmi
vous ici il y en a à qui ça parle ça
donc c'est important de trouver une
solution
j'ai un combat et j'ai un rêve
mon combat c'est de diminuer cette
souffrance qu'il est totalement inutile
imbécile et j'aimerais partager avec
vous ce combat j'ai aussi un rêve le
rêve c'est de développer d'entretenir
donné l'envi d'apprendre à tout le monde
aux enfants aux adolescents et aux
adultes
parce que quand on a envie d'apprendre
on a envie de vivre pour moi les deux
sont liés
quand on aime apprendre on aime vivre et
quand on aime vivre une fois adulte on
ne bat pas ses enfants on ne prêche pas
une guerre où on n'écrase pas ses
collègues pour gagner le plus d'argent
possible
on a juste envie de vivre humainement
on pourrait commencer juste un instant
tout de suite imaginé
rappelez vous un enfant ou un adolescent
vous connaissez bien qu'elle ait eu des
difficultés à l'école et qui pourtant
avait des talents tout à fait étonnant
en dehors de l'école et cet enfant cet
adolescent derrière c'est peut-être vous
même porter un autre regard sur cet
enfant ou cet adolescent ne voyait pas
ses mauvaises notes
mais voyez ces richesses changer votre
regard est là tout peut changer
je vais faire un double appel d'abord
j'aimerais faire un appel aux
enseignants tentent l aventure des
intelligences multiples ya de plus en
plus d'enseignants qu'ils font et vous
allez découvrir vos élèves d'une manière
complètement différente
vous allez changer votre regard sur vos
élèves sur votre métier et sur vous même
avec parfois des résultats tout à fait
incroyable vous allez vous allez
redonner vie à des élèves et un deuxième
appel ça serait à vous qui m'écoutent et
parce qu'on peut toujours imaginer que
les changements viennent de l'extérieur
qui ont tombé du ciel ou d'hommes
politiques extraordinaires qui nous
promettent monts et merveilles mais non
en fait le changement c'est en soi qu'on
peut qu'on doit le faire on peut le
faire et qu'on doit le faire donc ce
changement c'est de développer vos
intelligence multi j'aime bien une
phrase demandé la clé 10 et peu près au
fur et à mesure que vous vous autorisez
à libérer la lumière qui est en vous
vous permettez aux autres de libérer la
lumière qui est en eux de la même
manière je vous dirai au fur et à mesure
que vous vous autorisez à développer
toutes les intelligences qui sont en
vous vous permettrait aux autres de
développer tous
les intelligences qui sont en deux et à
partir de là tout peut arriver
merci